what's up beautiful babies welcome to an
episode
of get close
i'm your co-host gio do your best
christina aguilera impression christina
aguilera what the [ __ ] does she sound
like i'm not gonna do it for you no i
don't know how to do christina do you
britney spears that
um what this is get close
baby oh
with the get close intro yeah
oh my god britney spears oh my god this
is bad
sing that and then go and then but then
introduce get close
oh babe baby
welcome to another episode
why don't you stick around yeah
oh baby baby
welcome to
gekklos
that was really good
you rhymed it and everything that's
awesome
i'm a [ __ ] professional what the [ __ ]
did you expect you are very you are very
professional i am i'm a [ __ ] party
and i'm bark one hey what's up
i don't forget what track we're at yeah
how are you doing baby good how are you
doing i'm good these are my favorite
favorite times i like your farmer girls
outfit i know i've actually never worn
this shirt um there's like a tiger let
me show you there's a tiger on the back
of it yeah here i don't want to spill my
hair how come he never wore that shirt
before i [ __ ] the pandemic happened
and i don't get to wear any of my oh
right right check it out
hey that's pretty cool don't look
at my freaking derrieres
now look at my derrieres i've been
working on it really really
for a really long time dairy duffels my
dairy duffles shout out to theo vaughn
for coining the [ __ ] leche duffels
he's so funny when he calls him
chi-chi's yeah yeah he's a funny guy
um
but
uh so before we started filming you were
doing this thing where you're like think
of having that take that and you're
trying to get in the zone so that like
because we had just finished
uh filming for barbell we did some
workouts three videos for barlow brigade
yeah we did three different videos for
barbell brigade we worked out that was
one of them then we cooked yeah and then
in the middle of my cooking video you
went and you were answering some emails
i signed the lease for the jk vegas
office hey
you heard it here first
corresponded with uh some designers
going back and so my brain was like all
over the place you know when you're like
in that mode where your brain is kind of
everywhere um and now that we're working
what do you mean you're in that mode
like i'm like that all the goddamn time
which is probably why you suck at
everything but when you're when you're
extremely good at something like me
um with my brain's all over the place
and i'm about to come here and do a good
podcast with you i was trying to like
bring myself back in you know especially
someone with like add it's easy for me
to stay like
but then when i'm like that i'm not
doing a good job here so i'm trying to
like ground myself bring it all back no
no none of that [ __ ] [ __ ] matters and
then come back here yeah no that was
cool so then i was watching you do that
right um and i was thinking like oh
that's probably what bart means because
for me once it's showtime i'm like in
the zone like i have no kid i have no
husband i have no [ __ ] mortgage i
have no stressors it's right here right
now let's give it our all yeah me too
usually um yeah no but it's just
specific to filming
that's like how i get
and then i was trying to apply that
because i was watching you try to get in
the zone and like you know for me
sometimes when work is a little too much
or i'm stressed or whatever i kind of
bring it back into the family yeah
so then uh remember i was asking like
how do you do it because you're
experiencing the same amount well i mean
we can't really measure it right but
you're also experiencing your version of
stress but you don't ever let it reach
the family space and remember i was
asking like how do you do that [ __ ] like
how do you and you're like oh it's easy
i compartmentalize but like in theory i
get that right like i understand that
like right now it's the present moment
being the [ __ ] president but like
theory is not
real life
so then i don't know how to do that and
it wasn't until that moment where i
watched you try to get in the zone and
me sit here and be like i'm already in
the zone that i was like oh
that's what he means
i don't know if i explained anything
because it's so [ __ ] i think i think
it sounds like you're uh able to do that
for the filming but you're not able to
do that for the family but it's the same
uh yeah now i get it but like i just so
now i want to like work backwards and
figure out what that mechanism is that
like what is it that i value here that
i'm not either valuing or seeing yeah
but don't you care about your family no
i know it's honest it sounds like that
right and i don't think it's it is like
that you literally just said that right
now and everyone heard yeah yeah right
i'm working it out [ __ ] so just
[ __ ] pump the brakes yeah
thank you um
so i know it's not a caring thing
because i clearly care about it but i'm
just trying to now figure out like what
is the mechanism now
that like i need to like look at to be
like i'm here right now family bing bao
this is all that matters maybe it's uh
when you're in family mode that's your
comfortable space
so that's where you feel like you can
like let your hair down or whatever and
because of that my hair's always down
dude fine uh figuratively maybe that's
why like um
that's when that's when your stresses
come out too you know yeah maybe because
you know how like people ceo had us off
and now i'm like regular
civilian and i'm like [ __ ] all this
shit's happening because you know when
you're like uh like a typical job right
when you're at work and like let's say
your [ __ ] boss or your co-workers
pissing in the [ __ ] off and you feel
like you want to
slam the table or get a cup and chuck it
across the room you can't do that right
but when you come home and the minute
you walk through the door
you get to like drop your purse you take
off your emotional bra take off your tie
take off your suit kick your shoes off
are we in the [ __ ] 50s people people
still have regular jobs yeah they do but
[ __ ] they're not a lot of ties and
suits yeah yeah yeah they are yeah yeah
yeah yeah okay maybe if you work on the
east coast and wall street everyone's
still wearing those kind of things
stings yeah and then so they come home
and you know they
they can make those kind of noises yeah
because it's home now and it's
comfortable and they can't do that at
work and maybe so that's with you in the
family mindset uh maybe you're so
comfortable here that's why you you take
out your stress on the family and just
take it out on us
[Laughter]
no
but no
no but i think it's it probably has to
do with me finally feeling like i'm in
my safe [ __ ] space and i'm the zone
like i'm in that
like comfort zone that i i let it go but
yeah i definitely shouldn't be doing
that because i like how you operate like
i like that
you're able to leave that behind
and and it's still like it just feels
like you have
there's like if i were to only meet you
as a dad i'd feel like oh [ __ ] i think
dad is his full-time job because you're
just so
like present
i try to treat being a dad as a job
like not as a job as in like a good
thing you [ __ ] like a responsibility
but like but like a role yeah you know
like i i feel like
um at who i am now in 2022
i have a few roles that i play
and so every role
i really try hard to do my best to do a
good job so at barbara brigade i'm a
creative director
so i really try my best to make sure
that creatively culturally the brand is
going the way it needs to be you know
jk i wear two hats i wear
the business owner hat and when i'm in
the business meetings with joe and stuff
um it's very like cerebral more
strategic uh thinking about things
logistically we're not [ __ ] around
but then shoot day at jk news you're the
one that's [ __ ] right i'm a clown you
know i don't give a [ __ ] like
someone can log into our youtube to
upload a video i'll give a [ __ ] don't
tell me that [ __ ] because i'm [ __ ]
i'm clown mode you know and then so when
it's at home time
uh
and it's time to time to be a dad i
really like
look at being a dad not as just an
umbrella statement but you know when you
like get hired for a job you have roles
and duties
for me i have my own like listed out
roles and duties
that uh i give to myself yeah so that i
have a north star with that role too
yeah that's super cuny yeah it's super
cuny do you think you can hyper focus
on these things because you have a dd
um right because like that's what i've
heard from you and just other people
that like
one of the things of add is obviously
your your focus is split on like a
million things at once so there's always
noise happening in the brain um
but now when it's focused it's not just
regular focus it's hyper focus
if i can get something to occupy the add
i can get into hyper focus
do you think that that you being able to
play these roles is that
yeah i think um so that's why i think
it's really important for me to immerse
myself
because like you know when you kind of
have like um
like a dj right and you got like one
hand on each turntable
like that like how come djs have
turntables now because there's no discs
that are playing oh it's it's still part
of the um
the trickery traditional it's a part of
the tradition it's part of the ceremony
just have some [ __ ] spinning in there i
mean it's same thing with magicians why
they got top hats they should be having
like five panel truckers when was the
last time you name the most recent
[ __ ] magician that has a top hat
freaking chris downs row
no one wears [ __ ] top hats you loser
yeah they do they they pull buddies they
pull them out of the house all the time
nobody has a [ __ ] top hat anymore
yeah they do all right fine anyway so
yeah you know how djs they go like this
so when you're listening to one right
they're listening to the the other thing
that's going on and they're about to
like you like slide that in so i think
like with 80d it's kind of like that
where if the other parts are occupied
then you can hyper focus so with taika
um i i let the uh
his world try to take me over
and then so he's up to all kinds of
shenanigans but then that really helps
me like hone in on being a dad
you know so i'm not like no i don't know
so i'm not like listening to him i'm
trying to like hear and feel him
what's the difference between listening
and hearing oh there's a huge difference
so like um because if i'm stressed out
it'll be like this let's say i'm
stressed i'm trying to make food i know
we got we got like you know we got to
wake up early you got to sleep sleep
sleep early wake up early and all that
stuff right so taika might be going like
probably look at this picture peppa look
at this picture look at this picture
right
um if i'm not like
hearing or feeling him i'm just
listening on my [ __ ] pictures
aren't even that [ __ ] important
go away i don't have time for this
[ __ ] [ __ ] right i'm very annoyed
like that right
but if i'm in his world and i'm not all
stressed out by the outside things i'm
in the dead zone
what he wants is what he's really saying
is
papa i put my heart on this paper and i
really and i'm so proud of it and it
would mean the world to me
share this experience with me because
out of everyone in the world you're my
most important oh my god that's
beautiful yeah and i think when parents
are busy we don't hear that part yeah we
just hear the we gotta wrap up dinner
cause we gotta put your ass to [ __ ]
bed yes i gotta wake up at five to go be
a [ __ ] firefighter tomorrow you know
it's like that's the normal stuff so
you're you're not listening and feeling
i'm sure the firefighter ones are doing
that but not everyone's a firefighter
but i get what you're saying yeah so
like that's why i like to be in his
world so that i can like i'm not just
listening to his words yeah i'm trying
to feel him
um which i i
see and hear you do the same thing for
sure i definitely do it too um
uh for sure i just don't know if i've
like in my like it's a feeling more so
than like a cerebral explanation behind
it i'm just good at articulating it you
know but i think like that's why i think
we make a good team because obviously we
both run businesses the same business
and we both are parenting taika and so
there are times where like i don't know
it in the moment because i'm so [ __ ]
busy or whatever uh but uh taika will
say something i heard it with my ears
but then i hear you respond with your
heart and i'm like oh there that's
awesome like at least one of us is
responding with their heart and then i
didn't end up like uh missing what he's
trying to say by me rebuttaling
something stupid you know yeah so i
always have your back i mean i'm picking
up the slack you know which is not very
much slack
i think i have like i need a back brace
um anyone out there listening can i just
can you guys recommend a back brace from
all the [ __ ] family carrying that i
do yeah if you actually need one there's
a lot out there
i don't know
i'm so [ __ ] dumb i sidetracked myself
you actually were saying a really nice
thing about me and i [ __ ] killed at
my own moment
no but um
okay that's the difference between
listening and hearing and that's how
you're gonna be present yeah and um
you know i think i'm just trying to do
and undo what my parents did what are
you trying to do and what are you trying
to undo
so you know like um
no shame on them but a lot of immigrant
parents because they're in a in this
country or wherever they immigrate to so
australia new zealand canada wherever
right they're not in their home country
they're the blank canadian blank
american blank australian right
and whether they come from nigeria asia
mexico wherever
they're in survival mode they're trying
to make it in this new country and
really put food on the table
so
they're
working on the surface level
because they're just like i got to get
[ __ ] in order i just need to get my kid
to graduate somehow finish his homework
they're just thinking about that you
know they're not thinking about that
deeper level
and because of that
i don't like me personally i don't have
that much of a relationship with my
parents which i also notice people in my
generation just generally don't because
the parents never really try to
understand them but compared to
um
some of the kids that are second third
fourth generation that grew up here
they've been having conversation with
their parents
you know like even they'll like talk
about the guy that they're dating
um how they make them feel or whatever
and then with me i'm like damn you could
talk to your parents about that kind of
stuff like all my relationships i've
been kept hidden
you know so it just feels like such a
deep
relationship almost as if their parents
are also their best friends and they're
just so much closer because of that and
they share their wins together because
of that
and i just feel like wow like how much
more
the parent-child relationship can be if
you open those doors yeah so for me i
really try really really hard to open
those doors because that's what i try to
do yeah and what i try not to do is let
my own personal perspective of how
busy or
stressed out i am
um and not try to let those affect the
true relationship
that tycho is trying to have with me
yeah no you're really good at this
because he's trying i mean he's trying
to play like in his imaginary land all
day right and then we have all been
there we've all played like hide and
seek where ass is sticking out or
whatever and it's easy to be
you just got the visual that's [ __ ]
cute it's easy to be the stupid adult
and go oh my god he's sucking even how
to play this game right
um
but what does that do for the
relationship
it does yeah you know but if you're
there with him
like sometimes all he wants like like
i'll really like
try to like think about the same
scenario in like 10 different ways right
like one time he i think you were
working in the in the kitchen or
something and i know that you're cooking
so i know it's going to take like an
hour before you even have a break do you
admit that i'm in the kitchen cooking
oh i'm so sorry it was your mom in the
kitchen cooking i mixed it i mixed it up
was it me or my mom your mom was cooking
doing a good job wait did is it
i don't know what it doesn't matter i
was making a joke okay um
and then ty goes like come here come
here come here and i was like what what
and it goes
hide on the blade because that's a good
idea right and i'm like yeah what are we
hiding under here for so i get
underneath it with him he goes we're
gonna wait for mama to come
and then in my mind i'm like are you
stupid mama's cooking she's not gonna be
here for at least an hour we're gonna be
in here for a long time but i don't want
to shatter his dreams because what his
true heart is feeling is i just want to
be peace in a pod with someone i'm not
caring how long it is i don't even know
where this leading he doesn't even
understand time yeah all he's doing is
just both me and him at the edge of the
swimming pool he just is holding my hand
and he goes i'm going to jump what are
you going to do
right and i could go oh it's the water's
so cold they're so deep or so it's like
all this [ __ ] [ __ ] so i'm like he
jumps i jump and so we're both hiding
there and we're just having a good time
when i could like take all that stuff
away and i just see him like feeling so
happy about it you know we're just
underneath there and um obviously he
waits a while and he goes oh [ __ ] mama's
not coming she goes oh maybe we got to
go do something else so he's going to
make up his own mind so instead of me
shattering his dreams by going mama's
not gonna come here she's cooking
he will
learn himself and i just keep following
him the whole way through yeah and uh
moments like that i'm like man there's
probably tons of moments like that that
i had as a kid but my parents just
missed it because they're so fixated on
like the adult life yeah you know yeah
so i really try to like
uh be a kid with him yeah and have that
rapport with him so he like really feels
that i'm playing his game and he's not
playing what i want yeah that's super
cuny
i'm so happy he's your uh you're his
papa what that's really cool i mean
cause listen listen to what you're
saying like that's such a [ __ ] rad
enriching really uh uh upbringing for a
kid
like um my mom's staying with us right
now
um which has been really nice it's the
best yeah
and um she plays with tyka and it's so
cuny because i've never experienced or
i've never seen my mom in that way
um now my mom's retired she's been
retired for several years now
uh so what she primarily does is retire
people [ __ ] right like she gardens she
like fixes her house up like she spends
time with her grandkids so now her
stress level is super low like it's to
the point now where they're seeking
problems like that type you know yeah
so then the other day her and tiger were
playing and like um i forgot why they
were in the room but they were away from
us i don't even think you were home and
like i can hear him going like i'm going
to kill you i'm going to get and she's
going oh my god and then
they're playing with a little stuffed
animals and then she's going no no
please i'm a good guy please don't do it
he goes all right fine if you're a good
guy then we're on the same team or
something like that but it was just so
cute to hear my mom tap into her
imagination and keep this like
[ __ ] ridiculous storyline going i had
never seen that or like
she was not like that with us because
like you said immigrant parents trying
to [ __ ] provide like i did not have
that at all
so like really it's really touching and
it warms my heart that like my son has
that you know and that i even get to
experience it because i mean i'm still
like we're all all the ages we've lived
you know like we're all five still like
that comes out whether good or bad you
know so that five-year-old or
whatever year old is still in there
within me then i'm going oh that's so
cute i could cry it's a [ __ ] cutie
like i could cry right now i think he's
so [ __ ] cute
yeah i love seeing him with your mom
um especially like just by choice
because you see his like skinny long
body and those tight ass pajamas
he's in a phase right now where he only
wants to be in pajamas yeah and he like
runs over to your mom and he just looks
so comfy and like all these blankets and
just like sitting next to her watching a
movie yeah it's so cuny it is super
[ __ ] cuny um so
the other day you asked me this really
deep question
and i never really got around to like
um
asking where it came from
so you know we've been running our
barbell brigade get lean program where
we're trying to get shredded but we're
trying to maintain power lifters and
like strong right
um and part of the shredding aka the
losing weight or leaning out is we have
to hit a minimum 10 000 steps so we've
done this thing where um before every
training session we'll walk around and
that's kind of like a mini podcast
session because we always talk about how
we don't really get enough like
one-on-one time yeah
so in one of those talks i don't even
know if you remember this but you were
asking me um
out of the blue too or at least for me
it felt like it was out of the blue you
were like uh are you proud of how we're
raising taika and i thought that was so
profound like i thought it was such a
deep question
um and obviously i gave you my answer
but like where did that come from like
what
what prompted that question i can't
imagine a lot of people asking that
yeah especially at this age right like i
can probably see it once they're older
and they
they're gonna go to college because i
think at that point you realize if you
did a good or bad job right no i think
most people ask themselves that question
and now a word from our sponsor better
help
how well would you take care of your car
if you had to keep the same one your
entire life
damn i love that question that's how our
brains work so why wouldn't we treat
them that way i love that because we all
know after certain
miles we need an oil check or we need to
lift up the hood and see what's going on
in there i wish that our like bodies
would be like you know our hand would
like change a color i mean i guess it
does right
when it needs some help but i wish our
brains had like like a little icon or
something that goes like hey let's check
it out but it doesn't but we should be
viewing it that way so how we care for
our minds affects how we experience life
and that is a hundred percent true so
it's important to invest time and care
into keeping them healthy and i couldn't
agree with that statement more like
it's been in
ingrained in us that every year we need
to get a physical exam right just to
make sure that everything is oiled up
and properly working and you know we we
add more
years to our life than subtract from
them
and i as far back as i can remember
that's always something that's been like
really instilled in us but why not our
brain whereas we know through study and
studies and science and experiments that
our brains can really affect the health
of our body right
you know it can really affect how like
the statement says how we view life
so
when i heard that better help
exists it made me so happy to know that
we have so much access to licensed
therapists at our fingertips because
some of us live in areas where we don't
have you know the access to the the
the caliber of therapists that we need
some of us might live in a rural rural
area where we can't just get in our cars
and leave or we might just be you know
in a place where we don't have the right
support so it's really dope that better
help exists because
better help is an online therapy that
offers video
phone and even live chat only therapy
sessions so
you don't have to see anyone on camera
if you don't feel comfortable doing that
it's much more than affordable
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy
you can be matched with the therapist in
under 48 hours okay and for everyone
listening right now we are hooking you
guys up with 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
get close that's better help h e l p
dot com slash get close
when they're on their death bed and they
[ __ ] themselves
i think most people they're like
all over and they're like
[ __ ] did i live a good life
you know that's what i think
um for me
i always feel like um
like whether you like it or not
your life
it's it's like uh what's the word
it's like a record
it's gonna play
right it's like
in a circle and
it's up to you
whether you want to
live life
or have life happen to you
you know and i think a lot of times
people don't even know they have that
choice
if they want to live their life or let
life happen to you like
um if you have a alcoholic pops and it
beats the crap out of you
you can't control stuff like that but
afterwards do you start a like shelter
for people like that domestic abuse
shelter do you make a movie do you write
a book do you turn that
uh a horrible event into a gift for your
life or do you are you held down by that
and now it's a crutch you know
so like with that kind of like
that
on and off switch that um i'm aware of
like i question myself a lot in a lot of
areas like am i living a life that
is happening to me
or
i'm
making sure things happen and someone
when i was like thinking about being a
dad and stuff
i wanted to see like
man because i kind of when i asked you i
actually had my own answer already i was
like man i'm actually really proud of
the dad that i am
and um and i'm like because all the
the
the lessons that i want to instill in
him
he's getting them
um i'm also allowing the creative
freedom for him to be who he is
and then he gets to explore and i feel
like i'm doing a really good job of
doing age-appropriate things like
obviously you see the toughest guys in
the world coming out of russia right
and they probably got some crazy uh like
really restrictive and regimented
upbringing starting when they're tight
as h uh crazy guys are coming out of
russia in what way all kinds of sports
oh okay athletic yeah okay right and
then they're just like you just think of
russian people and you're like man
they're tough because they have
regimented lives starting at like three
four years old right
um
but then also but then
the that doesn't always produce success
because
um the most innovative
comes from america where people are
running rapping going crazy doing the
craziest things so i think as a parent
you're always like
um playing this game of like balance
of is
is the upbringing regimented enough but
is it also creative enough to allow
innovation because they're almost
opposites right one is like do what i
want you to do they want to do what you
want to do
and so when i was thinking about that
i'm like you know what like the
regimentation i think there's enough
foundation there with the jiu jitsu we
go there every single day he has to work
hard or like uh anytime he sees an
elder like grandma or grandpa he always
goes and says hi and hugs them and
always says bye like there's enough
respect so i feel like as he gets older
i'll turn up their regimentation but
that child like wonder what that great
imagination that's only gonna be here
and if you wipe that out too early he's
gonna lose that for the rest of his life
so when i was thinking about what kind
of upbringing i'm giving him i was like
man i'm really proud of myself i think i
did a good job
um but parenting i think it's like a
kind of like almost like a three-way
street where you have the one person
the other person and then how they're
doing it together
so i can only
uh
i guess feel
one-third of how that is so i wanted to
see how you felt on your end and then
also how you felt a bus
about us being together and that's kind
of where the question came from yeah
that's super cuny i thought it was so
cool i was kind of bummed i didn't think
about it first
cause i was like well because i was like
um
i think because we both compliment each
other on our parenting you know like i
just complimented you on this podcast
right i was just like man i'm so happy
that you're his dad
and then you tell me like i'm so happy
you're his mom or whatever right and we
give her each other specific words
before that
i knew i wanted to make sure my sperm
touches your cervix
repeatedly over and over
when i saw you um
like take care of your nephews and
nieces and i'm like that is the mother
of my child in the future yeah yeah so i
wanted to make sure that
i jizz real hard through your vaginal
canal and then like goes right in there
fine that's not what i was saying
oh okay what i was saying though was
because it's something that we
communicate to each other it's not
something that's like at the forefront
of my mind that i'm like um analyzing
right so when you and i'm constantly
analyzing every aspect of my life i
can't say that i analyze like
um
i'm not like you in the sense that i go
hmm am i living life or am i letting
life happen to me because i already know
the answer to that always
like um i'm where i want to be always
like i've never um any time i feel
not challenged or bored or whatever
for as far back as i can remember
um i i know i'm gonna i can change it at
any point so that i don't ever really
think of that um if anything when life
is hap or like when things are happening
in my life i'm always seeking the lesson
in that specifically
um the negative things i'm always like
[ __ ] i'm perceiving it as negative but
as we've said many times um
things that happen in in in the world
our life or whatever they're not
negative nor are they positive it's
whatever
um
it's whatever we attach whatever emotion
we attach to it right
so like because i'm thinking that way
i'm not thinking like as a parent am i
doing or how do i feel about me raising
this kid you know so when you asked it i
was like ah [ __ ] that is so good
because for me because we complement
each other you're the only opinion i
care about
you know um everyone else can like
pretty much [ __ ] off
right and not in a bad way either yeah
but it's like why should they have a say
in how i want our family dynamic to be
yeah like if our family dynamic is um we
love each other so much but we're
calling each other [ __ ] and [ __ ]
all day but the love is there and the
and like i'm like i don't give a [ __ ]
what the outside world perceives they're
probably going hi mr and mrs whatever
and like being super respectful but
like on the outside but on the inside
their whole [ __ ] they have dark
secrets and like they don't eat together
and they're like
you know plotting [ __ ] bad [ __ ]
against each other so like [ __ ] like
that doesn't matter to me
um
but when you asked it i was just like
oh [ __ ] i
i never considered
um
how you thought you were doing
you know
so yeah that's i was like man i i wish i
would have thought of it first because
it was just so good it just felt like
such a like i said like it felt super
profound i see that you were able to
look outside of yourself and be like
you as yourself how do you feel like how
do you feel about
what you're producing yeah because i
also feel like um
i have full responsibility of taika
and i think maybe it also comes from one
of my pet peeves like i really hate it
when there's parents out there that are
like
like let's say their kids are crazy or
whatever or like um behaving
unsatisfactory
yep that they're like uh
you know i'm like no you're the parent
what do you mean what do you mean
like they just take the the
responsibilities of [ __ ] this
what do you mean i don't know what
you're talking about in terms of that oh
that happens a lot like especially like
when you go to the park and the kids are
going crazy right and you're like hey
your kids like throwing dirt everyone or
whatever and they're like
what what parent is i've never seen that
oh i've seen those kind of parents a lot
what did they do
[Applause]
they just feel helpless and they feel
like like like like the kids running the
[ __ ] yeah like the kids running the [ __ ]
the life is happening to them they have
no control over the kid the kid is its
own personality what am i supposed to do
you know that kind of thing
so like which is partially correct but
obviously you need to guide them yeah
they're definitely i mean they
definitely come with the mind of their
own
um
and that's why it's a two-way street
where
you can have your full plan of like how
you want to raise your kids but that
might not fit this specific kid yeah
right looking like my mom like she was
goody two shoes so grandma giving her a
ton of rules perfect for her
for me i'm super rebellious you tell me
all the reason to break all of them and
that was the worst way that you could
raise me whereas if she had another son
or another daughter that was just like
her that probably would have worked
perfectly so every kid you almost got to
raise individually right
and so um i think that also comes from a
place where like
i always want to make sure that
i'm in control
and i'm doing what i want
and um
the taika like our our offspring is um
becoming a person that like we're like
you know what when we passed away like
we we did a good job raising a nice
little young man yay
yeah not sure if i will uh
yeah
we got many years to see if that
happened because i mean he's only he's
about to be five dude
but so far so good
like the the things that i matter that
matter to me a lot
he has all of them what are they
so
the first first one
is love
um i don't feel like i grew up with much
love
and uh that you received a lot yeah i
didn't feel too much love in the
household i didn't feel like
uh if
i always felt like if [ __ ] hits the fan
i need to console myself because no one
else understands me so i couldn't really
share secrets or anything like that i
couldn't really feel like i could be
vulnerable with my parents i felt like
my my my parents were only going to
accept the best version of me yeah so if
i was the worst version i need to
like
i don't know deal with my own [ __ ] you
know so i have a lot of like distance
yeah
with taika um i want the love
to be there like i want to look into his
eyes and just see hearts
when he's when he's with us you know
yeah and and he has that like even the
times where i discipline him you're
going to timeout and then when he's done
with timeout he doesn't come back and
like
hate me like yeah yeah you put me in
timeout
he comes back and he goes i'm sorry papa
and he comes and hugs me because we have
such an open door relationship like that
yeah and just to kind of explain that
timeout situation um
we uh
what i think we do correctly in that
instance is that
we make sure he understands why it's
happening
you know and i think that helps a lot
because when we got our versions of time
out or discipline
um
it was never really explained it's more
so like you think about what you did and
it's like [ __ ] how is this this little
kid
gonna have such a
deep um analysis of a situ such an adult
situation because they're just
they're just there in their imagination
having a good time where the parents are
the ones that have all the rules
so like
he's not gonna know what the [ __ ] is
going on so like to tell them well you
think about what you did without any
guidance or explanation i think that's
really [ __ ] up and then that creates
like
resentment and anger issues because like
he or the kid is forced to like
deal with some really big emotions that
they don't even understand but like what
i like is um when that happens with
taika that you're like do you know what
happened do you know why
why you got when in timeout
like good decisions bad decisions like
consequences all that stuff
yeah there's always a brief debrief i
like it yeah cause i'm never gonna send
him to timeout
in a way he doesn't understand so that
he's just hating me for the whole time
like this [ __ ] or whatever i'm
never gonna send him there like that
and then um so i always and i also don't
want to go into lecture mode because a
lot of asian parents have a problem of
doing that you did this wrong you did
that wrong you did whatever wrong and so
you're just memorizing [ __ ] and you
never really can't critically think yeah
so i go why do you think i'm gonna send
you the time route right now
oh it's because i threw this when he
told me not to throw it okay and it goes
timeout right and then afterwards then
we debrief
and i'm like why did you throw that oh i
just really wanted to play blah blah
blah blah
i'm like but okay i understand you want
to play but was it okay to throw it at
grandma's head he's like oh no i should
have thrown around his head why not
because you can hear her she can bleed
all over the place and go hospital just
to get shots
like exactly so you don't want grandma
to go to hospital and bleed all over the
place and get shots right she goes no
you know like so
you know you've heard her go on these
crazy tangents like his explanations are
crazy but it's uh so i make sure it's
like fully debriefed
and then so like i think because of that
i think
it it like has this uh
repetitive behavior of
i'm never getting punished for the sake
of being punished i'm getting punished
because i a
wasn't using my noggin or i wasn't like
or there's already been rule set in
place that i need to learn self-control
or whatever you know
and i so i think like when he comes back
from timeout and he's sad and he's
crying and he wants to be consoled by
the punisher
i'm like oh man there's so much like
love here yeah because when i like got
punished i'm like man i wish i lived in
that person's house yeah like the the
concept of running away from home i've
been having since i was a kid
what's a kid how old
i was like five [ __ ] oh my [ __ ] i
[ __ ] hated you i want to get the [ __ ]
out of here five yeah cause you go to
your friend's house and you see how
their parents uh raise the other kids
and i'm a man there's so much love
there's conversation here they eat mac
and cheese and [ __ ] five yeah i'm like
his age yeah yeah yeah i've been wanting
to leave i'm just [ __ ]
since his age we've been going to
temples and doing like two hour like
[ __ ] ceremonies and on our knees and
bowing up and down like some not normal
[ __ ] you know
it's like it's like
my weekend people look forward to the
weekend i hate you the weekend cause i
know saturday we're gonna go [ __ ] the
temple and do this [ __ ] [ __ ] then
on sunday we're gonna go to temple again
and do another [ __ ] bull i couldn't
wait until it was monday that like my
weekend sucked so bad school was my like
fun time vacation recess damn my whole
life sucks so bad like the minute school
ended i'm like oh man why can't i just
stay in daycare cause once my mom picks
me up i was gonna [ __ ] suck
i never wanted to go home
i wanted to stay either at daycare or in
recess those are those were the
highlights of my day
yeah
so because of that like i want to make
sure he feels love and he has uh just so
much love at home so that's really
important that's one like the main thing
the second thing is i want them to
understand um
like earning you know like never be
entitled you want something you get it
so as small as i'm thirsty go get your
water
okay you know and he goes and he goes
and gets it and then obviously like
grandma will spoil him sometimes and go
get it from and i think that's grandma
that's her job that's her job so i also
want him to feel
both you know like you know what it
feels like to have extreme love from
grandma because i also have that but
also know if you want something you go
get it
and um and he understands that concept
to the tea you know because you'll be
like oh can i have this uh papa and i'm
like uh what do you have to do he goes i
have to earn it i'm like wow how do you
know about ernie and he goes you tell me
all the time
all right good job and i'm like what
does ernie mean he goes means i work
hard and do something and i get
something i like i'm like good job yeah
that's awesome yeah i think with that
like understanding love because i think
with love comes empathy
um so that's that whole side that i'm
like okay cool that in his little like
two-celled brain he's understanding this
thing you know
and then in the other side he
understands what working hard means
and as long as he has those two at this
age i'm like cool the other more
sophisticated things i could slowly
nurture yeah but at this
step when i was asking you like
um are you proud of
what we've done so far yeah i'm like he
has these two really important things um
to me i'm like i'm very very proud this
cuny i'm gonna add to that list because
for me uh one that i i really try to or
i'm gonna add two more that were
important to me yeah um is independence
um and and personal responsibility yeah
yeah so those were so important for me
that like
even as a little ass kid his basic job
is
to
um obviously go to school but even
before school was there like if he could
feed himself i would teach him how to do
that like what are the steps i remember
i would teach him how to like make what
was it like a peanut butter sandwich or
something really basic he can't get hurt
um
that and now he's super independent so
it went from like him like cooking
because it's fun to now him like uh
wearing the clothes i picked for him
putting that on to now him picking his
own clothes like like he's just he does
a lot on his own that now it's so
[ __ ] cute that like there's things
that i want to help him with he's like
no i got it and i'm like all right like
yesterday we were moving a box or
something uh me and me and grandma was
helping her with something
and he saw it and then he goes oh i'm
gonna help you guys and then he's like
dragging a box you know and it was just
the cutest thing that this boy is like
hey
i'm gonna i'm gonna help out too like
he's not a very needy kid you know i
don't know if that's a personality thing
or if it was something that was like
that i helped kind of guide him in that
direction the other one is the
personal responsibility and um i really
want him to be aware that um
no one's like if it comes to his [ __ ] he
needs to be in charge of it i love that
right and right now
it's physical things right because i
can't really explain emotion like even
then i'm trying to like if you're
feeling sad it's not because people made
you sad it's because you made yourself
sad yeah you know when he'll be like oh
papa made me so angry and i'm like no
papa's not feeling what you're feeling
you made yourself angry like that's
we're getting a little bit more complex
there yeah but something as simple as
like um not like when he wants a toy and
he wants to bring it outside of let's
say the house or the car and he wants to
bring it with him i tell him hey this is
your toy this is your responsibility you
need to take care of it obviously if i
see he's too tired of you know or he
can't manage it like one i probably
won't let him bring it but two like i do
have his back and i'll you know help him
if needed but if i feel like he can
handle it then he's the one in charge of
it so if he's bringing water hey where's
your water here mom can you hold it for
me no i can't dude you have to i'm
holding my own stuff i love that you do
that with them you know you got to take
care of your own [ __ ] and it was really
cool because it paid off yesterday well
it's paid off multiple times already but
yesterday's the most recent one
so he has like this big bubble stick
you know what i'm talking about so it ha
it's like a stick it's like a wand but
it has the bubble fluid and then you
could take it out and then blow bubbles
yeah okay so um i think i was preparing
lunch or something and i don't know
where he goes mom i spilled it
everywhere i just went everywhere and
i'm like what what did you spill dude he
goes it's in the living room it's
everywhere and i look and it was like so
he was smacking it i think
and
he managed to untwist the top and all of
the like he sprayed our entire couch
all of our windows all coffee table was
just like drenched in like this bubble
fluid right
and i was like dude he goes mom i'm
sorry it was an accident i'm like all
right fine you're right it is an
accident you can't control them like but
man you can't like it has
yeah i went into electric mode right um
and then so i'm like okay let's you know
let me go clean it up and without
thinking because i just want to solve
the problem really quickly he also runs
behind me and he's like mom i need but i
need um napkins too and then and then so
he starts helping me clean and we're
both cleaning and like grandma's
cleaning and stuff and then i forgot
where i went but i had to get something
else and he stayed cleaning and at that
point i'm like his little ass hands he's
actually making it worse than making it
better right so i'm like dude don't
worry about it i'm gonna just clean it
but thank you thank you so much for
being honest you know i was i was
highlighting all the the correct
behaviors that he did and i was letting
him know like thank you so much for
letting me know i know you were scared
to tell me but you told me and i was
really brave of you and i'm um you know
i really appreciate you being honest and
telling me the truth i said thank you so
much right
and then uh he goes
uh and then i'm like but don't worry
about it i'm gonna clean it and he goes
no mom i made the mess it's my mess i
need to clean up my own mess and i was
like
you sure do dude go for it good job i'm
like that's a good leader man
you know and it wasn't good because he
just he has his
five-year-old add yeah yeah and now he's
like touching [ __ ] and he's making it
worse but drawing pictures with the
selves basically basically i had just
wiped it and then he goes and puts his
hand print on there because now it looks
cool but i was just like this is so
[ __ ] red yeah like this is so cool
so like
um [ __ ] like that i'm like wow it's like
really it's like really paying off it's
really cute
yeah like um with the whole independence
thing that's something that is really
important to me too
so any like protocol that we've set in
place i always try to uh
like ensure it keeps happening
but then this is where i feel like it's
hard being a parent because there's a
fine line that you're always trying to
like you know with like the whole
regimentation and then hearing the child
you know so like when we're staying at
your mom's house
uh taika knows how to put on his own pjs
and underwear after a shower right so
99 of the time put on your pjs and
underwear and he does it on his own
sometimes he feels lazy right and he
goes papa can you put it on from me
and uh when he says i'm like no you
gotta put on yourself you know how to do
it then you'll put it on but the hard
part about being a parent is hearing the
difference between this papa can you put
it on for me versus papa can you put it
on for me
because excuse me if i'm busy they sound
the same to me right and i'm like no and
i just gaffe it off you know go put on
your own you're not gonna do it i'm
trying to like maintain that protocol
but one time i was like no you
and i'm like oh he wants to have a fun
time putting it on this isn't a i'm lazy
do it for me
this is a is there a way you can like
put it on and i dive into the clothes or
like jump into that oh you heard that
[ __ ] heard it in there you know because
i can i could hear like oh he's goofy
because you're also a [ __ ]
mischievous mofo that's why this is like
goof goo fun time like he's not saying
it out of laziness which is easy for
parents to just rule it out as oh you
just [ __ ] being lazy again it's
so easy to like assume the worst of your
kid you know so i looked at him and he
looked at me and i was like okay
so you know i made like the whole all
pick and then
yeah and then he like stuck his head in
and then he's like put his arms up and
then we just had a good time we started
like wrestling and i started kissing him
you're definitely the fun parent that
ain't me man yeah we're just having a
good time and i'm like and after
afterwards
i
left them
and we had this understanding like
papa understood what i wanted oh
that's so cute
he's four right he doesn't know like
like um can we have a
can we have a creative improvisational
session of doing uh very that's exactly
what it is redundant repetitive tasks
yeah he's not going to ask for that he's
just going to say things like
purple can you put it on it's just all
feelings yeah it's just all feeling
right because when he's lazy he's like
can you just put it on exactly it's the
emotion and then can you put it on yeah
so like being able to hear the
difference when you're not even facing
him right because you're so busy i'm
probably packing something or doing
something and i just hear it and i have
to go
slow myself down and go oh he's not
being lazy it's easy to assume the worst
of him he just wants to have a good time
because if once you shut those down
enough yeah no you put on yourself no
put on yourself and put on yourself then
eventually that you close that door and
he goes well i'm never going to play
with popularity
and that's so true
i know so i'm like i'm i'm always trying
to like be outside of myself yeah so
that i can be aware because it's really
easy to overwhelm yourself with your own
[ __ ]
and then you end up having these
blinders on and then
you're not like opening yourself to the
the potential of what the relationship
could truly be yeah you know they're so
cute yeah so i really try to like
try to do that the super cuny man
i know what a [ __ ] fun guy
yeah this dude um
i just i'm just learning so much i'm
just learning so much
like
myself about the world dynamics yeah
like everything emotions yeah things i
don't even know i could feel i'm just
learning so much about everything
through this little duty yeah and you
know like um
i deal with like like for business right
like i deal with a lot of outside people
and like
i've learned that with having a kid
like you have to say things in a way one
that they understand
two speaking
to them
you know like speaking to their heart to
their way of
understanding and like all of that and
yeah not speaking at them right and
understanding what their language is
yeah and that's literally
what i do when i'm doing business now
that i'm like holy crap like
every single member on my team or anyone
that i've ever interacted with is a
completely different child and not child
in a degrading condescending way but i
just mean like the vulnerable
creative cute little
like human that's really innocent yeah
you know
um and you like everyone understands
differently everyone takes an
information differently
everyone reads the situation differently
like to you i can be super direct cut
and dry you want it black and white you
want it straight right and some people
might perceive that as too cold kind of
rude um uh very unemotional care about
my needs or right right not a team right
so like so for you and and even for me i
don't even speak that way so i would
have to change myself so that i can get
to you so then i have to go oh okay this
is the hat i got to put on now so that i
can talk to you so that we have this
understanding whereas someone else could
be like a crazy empath and like they
might have had like a really sad time
prior to this meeting the first thing i
want to do is hey man how was it you
know how was it getting here and i can
already start sensing where they're
coming from like are they having a rough
time are they having a chill time cool
if they're having a rough time
hey what happened
we talk a little bit okay cool and now i
kind of know how to navigate it now i
will speak more softly and like you know
give them more space to speak but like
it literally is because
um
of like having a kid and i'm going oh
[ __ ] and and a kid that's its own person
already
right because every kid is its own
person
every adult was a kid so like
taking everything i'm learning
and applying with taika and the feedback
the instant feedback that i get i'm
going oh [ __ ] that's literally every
human right now
it's it's been pretty uh
it's been such a growing experience for
me
it's actually been um
very inspiring
and uh what's the other word like
it almost feels like it's a privilege
to witness you
raise taika me
what yeah why
like i don't know if you remember but uh
last week we went or two weeks ago we
went on a pretty long hike
yeah
and um what started off as like a quick
two miler yeah it was like an hour and a
half yeah we decided to go off to the
side and try this other hike because we
thought yeah we thought it was gonna be
shorter than it was
and um
like tiger does two miles like nothing
you know and we go on this other side
and that it started going uphill more
uphill more upgrades
so hard i didn't want to tell you guys i
[ __ ] up but i [ __ ] up i know and i
was like holy [ __ ] like this is [ __ ]
because i mean i'm trying to get tired
you know and i'm like what the [ __ ] i
was drenched in sweat what the [ __ ] is
going on
and then i was like no i got this is
cool this is the right way and i was
going [ __ ] i don't know if this is the
right way and none of us had hiking
shoes on and it started to get like
really like you know like you need a
hiking shoes
and then taika was like my legs are
getting tired my legs are getting tired
oh they're so tired i won't go home
right and i was like oh [ __ ] what do we
do because obviously the easy way is
suck it up get tough you know it's yeah
or carry them yeah yeah yeah but i'm
never i'm never gonna
succumb to that um i've never coddling
is not in my vocabulary right you don't
say
that's news yeah so there's there's the
collars there's the people that put
shoes on their dog's feet
you know that's that's not me
i'm not gonna put a down jacket on my
dog
and then there's people that will uh
you know like the the the easier way is
just like suck it up you know yeah
that's [ __ ] up and then i'm like well
if you suck it up the long-term effects
of that is i don't want to go hiking
anymore right like it's going to be a
chore it's not fun and my parents don't
have my back and when they think
retrospectively they're like mom
you [ __ ] up like like when when he's
like 25 and he goes hey mom you know
what when i was five and he took me on
that [ __ ] five mile hike
that was [ __ ] stupid and you told me
to suck it up you know and then now the
parent at like i don't know 60 or 70
years ago i'm so sorry what was i think
right
yeah we all have these opportunities in
the moment to not make to have not have
remorseful
situations in the future yeah right so
when that happened i was like okay i'ma
resist saying
suck it up the the easy [ __ ]
and then i was like [ __ ] what what do i
say and then i saw you
and your magic interact and like hey
taika did you see that you see this oh
look at that and he started to take his
eyes and feelings off his legs yeah yeah
i was trying to redirect him yeah and
then you're like you're going to be the
leader i'm the leader yeah you're going
to be the leader and then he's like okay
and so he's like i feel him uplifting
you know and then um and then so i was
like okay cool i'ma follow this lead
this is really awesome and so i join in
and then we start singing the song and
we're singing the song together and then
now it's almost like snow white and the
seven dwarves like just going through
nature together and then like now it's
like oh you hear the birds chirping so
like what was felt like a hot dry
environment that just felt like a
workout yeah turned to a fun little
exploration team and then we're just
like almost like a charlie brown group
and like
look at that oh look at the lizard oh
look at oh that's so cool and uh being
able to witness that
and i'm like
wow that's incredible because
the kid could have done the five-mile
hike and hated and never wanted to go
back yeah and cry and have a horrible
time and then go back and tell all his
friends how much of a horrible time he
had yeah or
he can have a
amazing time with his family make it a
very bonding experience and then tell
his friends next time my parents go
hiking you got to come with me that's
cuny you know what he remembers of that
hike what um during that hike he found
uh
like some butterfly wings and it
probably was from like a [ __ ] bird
eating a butterfly or something but he
found it and that's how he remembers a
hike he's like that's the one where i
found my butterfly wings huh oh that's
okay yeah yeah and it's all because you
were such a great mom and you helped him
uh see
that hike as that yeah whereas a lot of
other parents who might have been like
you know frustrated themselves or
whatever they would have helped uh it's
the same exact like plot points but the
narrative is different yeah and so it
was like very inspiring
and uh to me it's a privilege to watch
this cuny thank you
thank you i really appreciate that you
saw that um i actually get that from my
mom because i didn't even know what to
do i yeah i get that from my mind was
like suck it the [ __ ] up you know but
then i was like that's not productive
yeah yeah um especially at his age yeah
if he's like 25 that's different
bootcamp is different better shut the
[ __ ] up yeah but if it's like at age
appropriate you know i'm like okay four
years old what's the best and i was like
that's not
he's that's not what he needs to hear
yeah yeah i got that from my mom my
mom's really good at redirecting energy
and just how the space feels yeah and i
would catch on so much mom's really
charming
um and i think i get that from her and
the whole redirection of energy she's
really really good at that um
so i think i started picking up on it
because um there were times where like i
would be upset and i wanted something or
like i feel like my whole upbringing was
me always fighting for freedom
i always feel like it was me navigating
like how can i go to my friend's house
how can i go to this event how could and
i was always scheming something like
[ __ ] how can i convince my mom that this
place is going to be safe and i'm not
going to be a bad kid you know yeah um
so i always had so much anger because i
was always frustrated not angry in like
a destructive way but frustration i'm
like [ __ ] i need to [ __ ] spread my
wings i need something to do you know
and i would feel this angst like this
just [ __ ] itchy crawly skin feeling
um and my mom somehow would
like
make it okay
and it wasn't until i caught on that i
was like you're not gonna do that [ __ ]
to me you know um but
i say all that to say that i started
picking up on it and recognizing it and
then then i started applying it myself
you know and i'm like oh [ __ ] there's
like so many like it doesn't always have
to feel bad like it doesn't have to be a
bad thing
yeah so yeah now he loves
the hike because that's the butterfly
wings hike and he loves it so we're
going to ask him to do something cool
and fun again he's going to love it yeah
for a little bit i didn't even tell you
but i was just like oh [ __ ] is this the
right way and i was like yeah it is i'm
like sometimes you got to make it so you
fake it till you make it you know yeah
anila that you know is what i remember
from that hike my skeleton head no oh no
that's really cute but the the two
lizards [ __ ]
yeah they didn't want to stop either
there was two big ass lizards [ __ ] in
the middle of the road and you couldn't
even like they're like 69 i thought it
was a snake yeah some crazy like it was
like some crazy position and taiko was
like oh my god it's a snake it's a snake
i'm like i didn't
my initial no those were two lizards
[ __ ] i don't say that
thought no no it's just two lizards
they're just they're just
on top of each other no it's a snake
that sounds like a big snake i'm like
it's not a snake it's a lizard yeah and
then we got like maybe like six inches
away from them and they were like oh
[ __ ] well i'll guess i'll pull out and
then they like split up and i felt bad
me too i felt like oh man i could have
waited yeah i could have just stood back
a little bit let the dude finish yeah
but we were on a mission to finish
because yeah we were [ __ ] huffing and
puffing for sure yeah you're like oh
right around this turn we're going
downhill
i'm like this looks familiar i think
we're going down now i think it's down
and we were going down and then it went
back up and i'm like
i'm pretty sure this is the right
[ __ ] way yeah
i'm glad uh
i'm glad we got through that because i
wasn't sure everything changed you know
what i mean from like season of season
things look different and like we hadn't
been there in like over a year yeah so
i'm like i could have sworn this was a
way and i mean it was but it just looks
so different yeah
what's going on with your foot you good
i'm just touching it oh all right well
yeah it's been it's been uh it's been a
ride but it's you know i like that we're
constantly
thinking about stuff like i love that
you had asked that question you know
because i'm like that's so tight like i
feel like we're always on the same
wavelength in terms of those just like
our personal development and just who we
want to be as individuals and who we
want to be as
you know partners who we want to be as
parents like it's so rad and it's so
refreshing that like
you know i've been in relationships
where i'm like going trying to go up
what i think i'm going up and then i
look over to my partner at that time and
they're just kind of like still flat you
know and like it's pretty dope to like
look over and see you also trying to go
up because i'm like [ __ ] yeah like we
get to climb up together and it's it's
it's
like
rare
it feels like it's rare because we talk
to so many couples and you know we hear
so many stories of like
like how do i get my partner get
motivated or how do i get them to do
this or how do i get them to do that or
whatever and i'm like first of all you
can't get nobody to get [ __ ] anything
they don't want to get you know what i
mean yeah
um but it's it's so it's so rewarding
we have such a cool relationship
you don't think so i think of an amazing
relationship oh fine
because you're just like playing with
your toes so i'm like i don't know
what's going on
nothing yeah
yeah
all right so i guess that's it
i guess we've reached the end of the
podcast yeah i'm done my time limit for
compliments is over so now uh just get
dried up uh yep i literally have zero
positive things to say about you from
this point on okay what are the negative
things go
uh
yeah you [ __ ] like too many positive
things for you to [ __ ] say anything
bad that's exactly right
um on that note fine we'll leave it at
that uh thank you guys so much for
listening this was an awesome episode of
parents self-reflecting
right yeah all right well uh thank you
and we'll catch you next week bye
[Music]